hey guys it's dense the founder thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode was 14 14 yep drag along Tahiti
Tahiti after a long break mm-hmm very
long after what I I would say is the
best episode of agents of shield so far
I'm not gonna say it was a great episode
but it was the best one that the agents
of shield has had so far sir and of
course what do they do they take a big
long break it's been like is it three
weeks almost am I my mom dad and so the
this episode continues on from that one
where we you know see sky get shot and
they're trying to save her I think this
episode wasn't as good as the last one
but in terms of where it falls in agents
of shield it's one of the better
episodes because it actually follows a
story instead of antibiotic I mean
that's one thing you never been harping
on glad that they have a story going now
I wish I cared more about Skye's fate I
still don't but at least they are
telling the big story I love seeing you
know Bill Paxton my favorite actors you
know from way back in the day with
aliens you know he's the man so it's
great seeing him on here you know there
was some good action sequences here when
they storm the base there was some good
moments in this episode you again it's
always weird combinations of shields are
always like it's a good agents of shield
episode we never say it's a good I never
heard any of us say it's a good episode
of television I don't think we've gone
quite that far yet but it's a good
agents of shield episode for what
they've been doing so far is in it's
better than what they've done in a
definitely definitely better definitely
i still can't learn i wouldn't recommend
the show to anyone yet I'd have to see
more they have to develop more you know
of the characters and the plots and then
maybe I'd be like oh you know what it
gets good this is supposed to be they
were like it's even a new title it
agents of shield uprising yeah yes this
is like a whole new are I think Bill
Paxton signed on I think he's on for at
least four episodes so I liked him I got
he he brought some different type of
character wait to the show yeah
personality you know cuz you know with
sky and agent war there seem kind of I
know kind of blank even and I love even
Agent Coulson at times gets a little
repetitive and his mannerisms and Clark
Gregg's a good actor I'd always capable
of doing the
lot of good work but it seems like even
his thing he's gets kind of repetitive
he's doing the same thing every week
yeah so I liked it for what it was I I
hope they continue on with it um what do
you think of the ending with uh eyesore
isn't my thing with this the whole last
butcher named like Lorelai or
laura-leigh like she is a character you
know from thor marvel from Thor walt
simonson you know worked with loki a few
times can you know compel women are
sorry man oh yeah maybe a capella you
know gods and mortals to do her will as
we see the in this episode my beef with
this is that I'm excited to see jaimie
alexander network that's gonna be the
talk of this episode it's like Jamie
Alexander's comin at ya ass if she's hot
she you met her in purchase a nice
person she's a great actress like I like
but my beef with this is like they're
using somebody elses and it's Marvel so
it's all theirs but it's like you're
using something else to elevate your
show like that's not agents of shield
jaimie alexander is not gonna be on the
show week to week she's a special guest
which next week could be a cool episode
that's not gonna save the entire season
which worries me it's like just cuz sips
coming doesn't mean all the shows good
now it's like she's on it for one week
yeah and I'm excited to see here cuz i
love jaimie alexander but i wish they
brought her in for more of an arc like
yeah a little accident yeah right and
then you can have like a whole like okay
here's stiff and hairs right cuz if it's
what we think it is then it's just gonna
be a one-off yeah she'll come by the
roles and they'll go away little back to
Asgard yeah yeah then it's like okay
that was a fun episode but where do we
go from here where at least these last
two episodes were part of the agents of
shield right history I guess yeah part
of the actual show with the the main
character is nothing wrong with I mean
does Marvel something wrong with
bringing and care down the outside but I
feel like they're using it to almost
like elevate like a crush look it's a
crutch yeah I know it's like be your own
show first and then you can be even more
awesome by bringing in other characters
but be a good show on your own for so I
don't think the show is done yet that's
my problem with anything much more
consistency and broadening out all the
characters uh yeah I we still
they're still trying to like tease us
more with this with this agent coulson
death rebirth thing because I keep going
with it yeah because before they showed
how he came back right but now there's
like there seems to be more to this
because you got this alien dr. Manhattan
looking dude in the tube right that
that's that they're using to funnel this
whatever that g4 antidotal formula that
they helped save Skye with and you know
a lot of people are speculating that oh
maybe that that alien there's like a
Kree Oh or maybe it's something else
yeah but that's good it's just yeah the
mystery just hasn't grabbed me get the
things with even with sky cask idol
thing is like oh he was worried coast
was worried that sky would experience
the same pain he did you know like I
want to die let me die kill me it didn't
happen you know it's always mystery with
her birth and who her parents were and
what ability she has and what she is
whole destiny thing and I want a sky
needs to be a little more interesting
for me to care and I still don't care
about her destiny or what you know I
mean the whole thing I said at the end I
am excited to gmail exam next week I'm
excited to see this you know fight
between these two beautiful girls so
that's good that's going to be fun but
beyond that again yeah I just don't know
if I'm into the story as much as I wish
I was I like dope accent I love Bill
Paxton come on yeah yeah Garrity's
garroted yeah it is a second-in-command
guy yeah who fought with the ward for
long I did like dead badger between them
them tall I like that I also like that
Ward had a history with bill paxton's
character Garrett and he had worked with
him before so I thought that part was
cool yeah so I don't know hopefully they
developed that more in the future
episode right to give the show credit
it's not getting worse no it has its
getting marginally better largely but
it's just very slow but it is getting
better at to give it credit where
credit's due yeah so hopefully they can
build off of it and that's the question
so I don't know what did you guys think
see you guys love this episode are you
looking forward to next week's episode
with a jaimie alexander
is safe and that whole storyline what do
you think of the main characters for
agent scenario I think they can carry
the show right on it on its own can it
survive if it gets renewed what season
to kind of look like that that's a long
ways out alright guys you can post your
constable on the website think hero.com
or on our youtube channel think you're a
pro make sure to subscribe to that you
also find us on Twitter talk to Dennis
or Michael on myself about agents of
shield you know versus other superhero
shows arrow how do you compare the two
do you like both I can find us at think
hero i'm at griffin de and we have saw
the facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans
you